[Applaudissements]
né d'une mer magnifique qui posait pour
Picasso et d'un PA photogénique comme
Rudolf Valentino au-dessus de son
berceau on vit des filet des faet il
avait tout vraiment tout pour être un
très beau
[Musique]
bébé Léon à part quelques détails était
très beau
garçon deux têtes six bras un œil et
quatre jambes mais c'est pas
importon pardon on vous dira qu'à
l'école il fit toujours le premier quand
on lui posait des coles chaque fois il
répondait c'est vrai qu'il avait deux
têtes une pour lui l'autre pour non
comme elle remuait en même temps il
avait toujours
raison
Dio Léon à part quelques détails était
très beau
garçon de têtes si bras un œil et quatre
jambes mais c'est pas
important pardon il fit un très grand
pianiste g plus à droit que Chopin tout
seul il tournait les pages tout en
jouant à cinq mains au régiment c'est
pareil il de 20 tireur d'élite comme il
n'avait qu'un seul œil c'est lui qui
visait le plus plus
[Musique]
vite Léon à part quelques détails était
très beau
garçon deux têtes six bras un œil et
quatre jambes mais c'est pas
ant pardon il gagna au jeu d'unail le 40
m et rorta de médaille c'est beaucoup
pour un Français comme il avait quatre
jambes et que rien n'interdit ça il fit
premier et 2è on n'avait jamais vu
[Musique]
ça mot Léon à part quelques détails
était très beau
garçon de tête six bras un œil et quatre
jambes mais c'est pas un Bordon pardon
plus vieux que Mathusalem un jour il
quitte la vie et c'est sans aucun
problème qu'il monte à au par dit quand
saint-perre ouvrit la porte la première
chose qu'il vit c'est que le bon Dieu et
les anges étai tous fait comme lui et
attention les anges
[Musique]
di Léon à part quelques détails était
très beaux garçon
Gabri si bras un œil et quatre jambes
mais c'est pas un important comment mais
c'est pas
important ah bon et
[Musique]
oui